l'appareil a décroché trop rapidement
les passagers n'ont pas eu le temps de
se parachuter en douceur la capitaine
jennifer kessy originaire d'halifax a
perdu la vie dans l'accident
ancien journaliste membre des forces
armées canadiennes depuis 2014
elle est devenue ensuite officière
responsable des affaires publiques des
snowbirds elle avait étudié en
journalisme à l'université king's
college london welsh est une fatwa il
avait eu rire contagieux
un sourire lumineux opel était une
étudiante d'inoubliables se souvient son
ancien professeur
le pilote de l'appareil le capitaine
richard mc de gaulle de dieppe au
nouveau brunswick a été gravement blessé
dur coup pour sa mère c'est de savoir ce
que c'est monfils ou non c'est la
première chose la vie de son fils n'est
toutefois pas en danger
comme toute maman on est soulagés qui
les lions très très attristé de savoir
qu'il a perdu sa coéquipière qu'il
appréciait beaucoup que j'ai rencontré
le 6 mai quand il était ici très gentil
il y avait seulement des bonnes choses à
dire à propos d'elle richard mique du
golfe ont remis à dieppe et à moncton a
joint les forces armées canadiennes en
2006 il était avec les snowbirds depuis
l'été dernier il faisait équipe avec
jane qui si il sait qu'il va se remettre
physiquement on va avoir besoin de
l'épauler pour qu'ils soient capables de
vivre le côté de son 2e et si vous
voulez
les snowbirds avaient entrepris leur
tournée au dessus des maritimes dimanche
le 3 mai dans le but de remonter le
moral des canadiens en ces temps de
pandémie
ce jour là les néo-écossais les yeux
rivés vers le ciel ne savais pas qu'il
faisait leurs adieux à une des leurs ici
c'était dany blanchet radio canada à
halifax